but uh let's jump over to this we got
breaking news so i was actually this is
why i got distracted because i had i got
a notification on my phone we have this
from the hodge twins it's actually a
veritas video breaking leaked audio of
twitter all hands reveals employees
press leadership over what free speech
means
a plan for mass exodus due to elon
musk's questionable ethics and
questioning if president trump will
return to the platform
shout out to james o'keefe and project
veritas elon musk you need to reinstate
them immediately as soon as you gain
control of the company let's play this
uh this video and see what's going on mr
must plan on dealing with a mass exodus
considering acquisition is by a person
with questionable ethics the question of
attrition um you know as perak stated
you know one of the themes of today is
continuity and ensuring that prague and
this leadership team continues to
operate the business successfully on
behalf of our users on behalf of our
customers and that has obviously been a
big topic of discussion at the board and
as i mentioned an area that is important
to elon musk as well because of the
importance of twitter as a service with
no board in place who will keep elon
accountable and how elon made it clear
in public that a large part of the
reason he bought the platform was
because of our moderation policies and
disagreements in how we deal with health
this puts twitter service and trust and
safety as well as anybody who cares
about help on the platform in a very
difficult position twitter service the
role of our policies
and the capabilities we've built around
content moderation are fundamental to
keeping twitter safe
and growing i believe
that there is a lot of work we have to
do to continue making that better i want
to pause real quick in the middle of
this we got another minute but i want to
point out
conservatives are willing to stay on the
platform when they're getting censored
and the left is getting away with it
yeah the left is unwilling to stay on
the platform if conservatives aren't
getting censored so twitter saw the
formula you can ban a conservative and
most conservatives stay you ban a
liberal they freak out and revolt only
ban the conservatives this is evidenced
by the fact that by sheer fear that elon
might bring trump back they're leaving
the platform
i say it this way
when you had the weak parent in charge
of twitter and the little kid was
screaming i want an ice cream cone or
i'll hold my breath twitter's parag
agrawal and vijayagade were like okay
okay just stop screaming and i'll give
you the ice cream elon musk is the dad
being like okay go hold your breath
outside and i'll have the ice cream
inside you know you're not getting ice
cream but let's uh let's play and now
they're going i'm running away from home
and he's like goodbye yeah here we go
sometimes
that means more thoughtful moderation
sometimes that means making things
simpler sometimes that means changing
product incentives to be able to solve
problems through products sometimes
instead of policies during the last all
hands you said that you trust elon musk
the correct quote was we trust him so
who is we and talking to elon what made
you trust him and based in the
conversation i had with him
when we were excited to have him join
our board that was because as a major
shareholder an opinionated user
we wanted that voice in our boardroom so
that we could learn is there an updated
understanding on what free speech means
the question behind the question here
which is where might twitter's product
go as a private company in the future
once this deal closes to best gain
perspective on this as i said earlier
we'll find ways to bring elon for a q a
with all of you to understand better
what his vision for the future of
twitter might look like
i wouldn't say anything outright or
overtly crazy other than these people
are blind completely clueless
and they're right elon joining the board
was an opinionated outside perspective
that would help them but they they
blocked him so him coming in and saying
i'm taking it over good shake it up a
little bit they have ideological
blinders
they
talk about moderation policies
they don't have moderation policies they
have extremist policies that are driven
by censorship of views that they don't
like they talk about safety but almost
all their their rules on safety dealing
with the covet outbreak turned out the
science wasn't on their side over time
drugs that they
said didn't work actually worked the cdc
was wrong on mass the cdc was wrong on
the the effects of the uh immunizations
on people
we have to be a little specific though i
i think the the issue is that twitter
decided
one doctor was better than another
doctor when they shouldn't they
shouldn't be doing that youtube takes a
similar position in that they've
youtube's decided the same doctors that
twitter sided with are the correct
doctors and this is the problem youtube
you are not correct however i will say
on the mask thing
in what context
were you referring to the cdc mass
things
mass they were first saying masks
aren't needed right
and then they don't work and then they
said they're needed and then we found
out that the mass were not effective
against the size of the the virus but
but it is
and then it evolved up and down over
time okay so it was it was just strange
and it lost a lot of confidence of
people in the cdc on that issue i think
the most important point is that early
on
twitter was on the side of don't discuss
lab leak theory
and they were also on the side of when
dr fauci came out in march of 2020
saying don't wear masks twitter was on
his side and he was wrong about that he
came back out later and says okay maybe
you should wear masks and twitter just
flips with him i'm like you cannot build
confidence with people if you can't give
them a cohesive set of instructions on
what the plan is they would just come
out and say oh well the science changed
okay well i think the i don't know where
we're at with the pandemic
youtube has goofy rules i think it's
fair to say in addressing those goofy
rules
masks stop you from spitting on people
so they have a certain a certain degree
of effect uh effectiveness okay so so
the sanitation issue it turns out that
getting it from touching something okay
you have a one in ten thousand chance of
it being transmissible okay if you touch
a contaminated surface
but we were first told that
if you touch a surface
you have a high chance of getting it and
everyone was cleansing everything people
were cleaning the canned goods coming
back from the grocery store based upon
cdc guidance
it turned out that was wrong it created
hysteria subway cars were being
sanitized every day multiple times but
it wasn't necessary yeah this is uh from
this conversation the obsession with
health and the obsession with safety is
really disturbing it sounds like
rhetoric and maybe this isn't the
conversation to have the ethical
conversation but compared to the board
meetings we would have at minds and the
conversations this is complete insane
rhetoric where you're like yo if you're
going to spin this word around the house
like this you better let's talk about
what it means amen let's come back to
one point she said on there free speech
what does free speech mean free speech
means free speech except yelling fire in
a movie theater right you're allowed to
do that you're allowed to do that you're
allowed to yell fire in a movie theater
if it's empty no
no you're allowed but you can be
punished no you can't oh so this was
actually reversed i think in like 1968.
so it's brandenburg v ohio i think okay
the the initial ruling in the early
1900s was that well you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater and the supreme
court overruled that saying yeah you can
you actually can do that can you go into
a restaurant be like there's rats all
over the place and then everyone runs
out of the restaurant and doesn't come
back that's not a a criminal issue
that's a civil tort issue for you lying
same with fire
uh
you'd prob yeah you'd probably get sued
by the business but it's not a matter of
uh law but that's not a matter of
criminal law but let's go back she's
she's ahead a leader at
the organization i i assume and she's
saying well what is free speech
well this was her uh she was really a
question from from employees
also so the woman was getting questions
and she was asking the ceo it's
indicative that they still don't know
what it is if they're still asking the
question also i believe when uh oliver
wendell holmes said you can't shout fire
in a crowded theater he was using that
as a justification for censoring people
who were protesting the first world war
yeah
yeah that got overturned i think about
1968 yeah so they'd go into a theater
and yell just to get people right no no
so they were not actual he was using it
as an analogy
they were passing out flyers
that protested the first world war and
they ruled that you shouldn't be able to
do that and his justification is well
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
so you can't do this either some people
are pointing out that um perak agrawal
is was not born in the united states and
so the ceo who is dictating our speech
is that's very problematic that someone
who isn't you know from this country uh
my response to that is elon musk was
also not born in this country and would
also be dictating speech in this country
so um yeah either way you've got that
problem
so is it an issue i suppose the issue is
are our values being upheld and twitter
you don't i think twitter is
it is um
you guys ever play the game life genesis
on oh windows 95 negative you remember
that one
so uh
it's a bunch of little dots little
squares pixels that interact with each
other in unique ways and it creates
predictable it creates patterns based on
certain rules
and in the version i had you had two
colors
basically
if you have 100 blue pixels and you drop
one red into it the red gets engulfed
instantly it just becomes blue that's
what twitter is twitter is 98.7 percent
democrat voting democrat donating
anybody who goes in there and is
conservative is crushed instantly their
ideas don't make it anywhere you're not
going to be sitting in a twitter meeting
and they say how do we deal with this
this this problem of harassment and be
the lone conservative being like
uh it's not harassment what are you
talking about you're gonna keep your
mouth shut because you're one out of you
know 30 people and you know they'll
harass you they'll take your job from
you so you do nothing all of the
policies then start moving further and
further to the left and going insane and
so the people at twitter genuinely do
not understand how insane they've driven
themselves as i've often described it
jack dorsey built a big toilet and then
stuck his mouth on the end of it and
started eating the refuse he created i
know it's a crass way to describe it but
this is what happened
people went on twitter started saying
insane things to get traffic the more
insane they got the more jack himself
was surrounded by the insanity that he
had welcomed
so what happens then is i'm sitting down
with jack and vijaya and joe rogan and i
said yeah your rules are overtly biased
your rules are right and jack says no
they're not and i was like you have a
misgendering policy you can't see that
that is a outright biased rule that
conservatives are are confused by and he
was like but we're trying to help people
who might be suicidal and i'm like
you're not helping body dysmorphic
people you're not helping transracial
people no you live in a bubble you live
in a bubble you can't see out of so
you've enacted policies that are insane
to the average person
and that's for a miniscule percentage of
the population you're changing all the
norms for a
minority of a minority of the population
but we're talking specifically i would
say the minority is the leftists
it's it's it's not even blair white is
is a trans person blair white doesn't
agree with with what these people are
saying it's not even an issue of in my
opinion trans issues it's an issue of
ideology
so what happens is you have white
progressive liberals who claim everyone
else is racist they claim candace owens
is a white supremacist they claim larry
elder is the is the black face of white
supremacy
it is their fringe ideology that is
dominating and getting these rules made
it's not even an issue of
are black people upset over racism yes
many are but they're not the ones
enacting these changes they're not the
ones going into twitter and demanding
twitter do these things for them some
activists are psalm art it is this weird
fringe cult that is going in and making
rules for everybody else while believing
that they're the white saviors and you
also have the issue of the trans agenda
which is trying to groom
people that have dysphoria or issues or
might be migrating to being actually gay
and say you're not actually gay you are
trans
and you need surgery and you need to but
again though that that's white
progressive women doing that correct
it's not so so you know a lot of people
bring up the idea of like a trans agenda
or whatever and
i'll say okay in the context that
doesn't refer to an individual who is
transgender it refers to the cult
because when you see a video of a white
liberal woman who is a straight married
woman but she's talking about how she
wants to teach kids these things it's an
issue of the cult
white
weird progressive fringe politics i
believe social media has has wrapped
them into a bubble of incendi
where they push policies that regular
people think are insane
i want to make it it's possible i'm
being pedantic with myself here i want
to make a slight correction the 1919
court case we were referring to about
yelling fire in a private theater it
wasn't even the person protesting the
first world war i looked it up to double
check they were just protesting the
draft in the first world war so it's
even worse than that but i wanted to
point that out and sam i hear what
you're saying but i think it's fair to
call the trans agenda because even
though not every single person who's
considered to be transgender is on board
with it it seems to be how they're
unified and behaving as a political
force that's what i'm saying if you're
saying it's an agenda to encourage
transgender or gender ideology
sure
if you're saying it's a trans agenda as
if transgender people are the ones
behind it i would say i disagree with
that because there for one the
transgender community is very very small
and if you go on twitter and if you look
at these videos it is typically like
white liberal women
however there are many non-binary
individuals who are advocating for this
stuff as too i'm not saying they're not
i'm just saying
i think it's important to call out the
ideology while recognizing we're friends
with blair white who's amazing and
doesn't agree with them we also have a
similar situation with white liberals
male and female
pushing the in
the immigration agenda
that is not the dominant theme or the
dominant industry for the hispanic
community in this country regardless of
their from south america cuba poor
puerto rico or any place else okay
it's being pushed by the white liberals
and i should mention this of the
hispanic people i have met who are legal
immigrants they are not a fan they are
not fans of illegal immigration so the
idea that like this is an issue that is
being pushed by you know hispanic voters
as a block is ridiculous you're right
very often it's just it's white liberals
who want to pat themselves on the back
virtue signaling or big businesses that
want cheap labor thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you